I had the idea to do a 10K Q&A sort of
thing about a month ago when I was at
9,000 subscribers and somehow the
passage of time took place and now I'm
creeping up on 15K so I don't really
know how that happened um but in all
seriousness I appreciate all the support
and I don't know it's just cool to make
things and have a lot of people enjoy
those things so that's been cool thank
you part of the reason I'm making this
is because I want to share some updates
about what's going on with the channel
and kind of what I want to do with it um
you may have noticed that I am posting
more often and indeed I am posting
weekly at the moment on Thursdays and
I'm currently trying to alternate
between the higher effort content you
know the the kind of deep dives into a
particular deck building subject and the
more fun content where I you know for
example analyze a precon or just talk
about whatever it is that I want to talk
about that day
um so that's currently what I'm trying
to do uh and there one particular type
of kind of off-week content that I going
to start next month is Patron Deck
reviews these Deck reviews are going to
be very much in the style of the pre-con
review so I'm going to try and figure
out what a deck is trying to do how well
it's doing at that goal and some
potential routes for improvement so as I
said that's going to be starting next
month I'm going to be picking decks
through a lottery system and you can go
check out my patreon for more
information about that also on my
patreon I am going to be posting a
glissa dect tech very soon so that's two
different reasons to check out my
patreon that's pretty cool uh with that
out of the way uh let's get to questions
and these are going to be mostly taken
from a post I made on patreon
recently what's the story behind your
username about a year ago ago I needed a
username for some website or other and
just my two second on the spot smash
together of words was salubria snail um
cut to a few months later I was trying
to come up with a name for my YouTube
channel and that one popped back into my
brain and I kind of liked it you know
it's Snappy it's alliterative has a fun
word seems pretty cool so that's what I
went
with what's your MTG
story so I learned to play Magic in
2011 and the way I got into the game is
that Mark rosewater gave a career Day
presentation at my middle school and at
the end of it he handed all of these you
know 11 and 12 year olds uh starter deck
from from
M12 uh and so I I got the red one and
then I just went from there uh I I
started playing Limited in 2013 so my
first draft was dragon's Maze and then
in early 2014 I really got into the game
I started playing standard and
EDH uh and then I've played kind of off
and on since then um picking back up
very heavily in early last year um
building starting to build a whole bunch
more Commander decks what was the first
card deck or mechanic that excited you
I've always been a black player and my
first deck that I can remember was a
sort sort of black life gain is deck it
ran a fair amount of removal because
that's just who I am as a player and the
specific interaction that I can remember
between two cards is it had tormented
Soul which is an unblockable creature
and vampire outcasts which is a
bloodthirst creature which means it's
bigger when it enters if uh an opponent
was dealt damage so it almost always
came in as a four Mana 44 LifeLink which
honestly not bad LifeLink is one of the
best keywords pretty solid what is your
favorite Magic
card that
one I shag Weaver has always been a card
I love and it's funny because I feel
like it's known for cube you know you do
the splash yok but I've never played
with it in Cube um the place I've played
with it was in standard grixis control I
ran three of it and it was fantastic in
the matchups it soaked up damage for my
deck which sadly did not run life gain
and against the control matchups of
which there were many because that was
standard at the time uh all the
abilities are great the the plus two you
can Exile cards uh which is great
against aorus control who kind of Cycles
through the deck repeatedly um the minus
10 if your opponent lets you get up
there just blows out a control deck so
just a great card all around and I also
just love the flavor um I'm a big horror
fan in the idea of this kind of
unknowable Otherworldly entity who's
weaponizing the fears of its foes to
destroy them that's just that's
incredible to me I love it what does
your rule zero conversation look like so
this is a good question and I think for
starters it's good to make sure that
decks are at similar power levels so you
know figure out what decks are doing how
fast they're doing them and just make
sure that things are comp that there's
not going to be any crazy discrepancy um
and then next I would say for for
middling to lower power levels it's good
to check in uh with kind of what
people's intentions are for the game and
what they find fun um so there are
things like board wipes or combos or uh
heavy duty Stacks pieces where some
people might not have as much fun if
they're playing against those that might
not be a thing that they want to see a
lot of in their game and I think it's
it's fair to kind of try and navigate
that to some extent um I I will
sometimes ask somebody not to play a
particular deck even um for example I
have a friend who has a turrid deck and
three Knights out of four I don't want
to play against a turrid deck not not
really no uh and I think that's that's
fair although there are kind of there
are some limits to kind of what you can
request of somebody and I think it's a
tricky thing to navigate you know you
can't just ask that every deck your deck
is bad against uh isn't in the game
that's that's not really fair um but at
the same time you know I think when I
build a deck if it's a particularly kind
of feisty or mean or suppressive deck I
I have some understanding that it might
see less action than a deck that is you
know nicer or you know offends people a
little
less if you were in control of the EDH
band list what would you do so the EDH
ban list is tricky because it's really
trying to be two different things it's
trying to dictate what's too strong for
cedh and it's also trying to dictate
what's not fun for casual and I think
answering these two questions at the
same time is difficult um and we can
think about some different cards that we
might think about banning so let's say
doite extortionist um very good card
maybe it should be banned um but that
would be mainly a ban for cedh and the
top levels of of kind of high power
casual because it doesn't matter for
random mid-range beats decks there
aren't that many artifacts at that power
level you're not going to be doing the
same sort of value Loops um it's just
not going to have the same horrifying
power level as it does uh at at other uh
EDH
contexts similarly we could think about
a card like Armageddon you know you can
ban that because it's not not fun but
you know it's not that's not a ban in
the conventional sense of a card game
you know you're not Banning it because
it's too strong you're Banning it
because it's unfun and I think there's
there is a little bit of tension there
that you're trying to kind of solve
these two different problems so really I
probably wouldn't be that
comfortable uh dictating a whole bunch
of new card allowances or disallowances
for EDH just because I think it's a
really hard thing to do um what I would
encourage is you know players having uh
more of a rule zero conversation more of
kind of a conversation about what they
find fun and what they don't want to see
in their game you know you shouldn't you
shouldn't roll up into a game with with
strangers and destroy all their lands if
they're just trying to play their their
upgraded precons or something um so I
think it's it's good to have an
understanding about that and I think
that's an okay solution because EDH
fundament mentally is a social game a
social format um if I had to ban one
card for very Petty personal reasons it
would be farewell uh I hate the card I
just I think it's very lazy design it's
it's a six Mana board wipe that has no
downsides other than that it's a six
Mana board wipe it's probably not broken
from a power level standpoint but I just
hate to see it it's lazy don't like it
it also kind of uh crowds out um other
cards like merciless eviction or AER
command so I don't know not not a fan
not a fan of
forwell what's your opinion on
explicitly political mechanics like will
of the council the cat came back uh I
actually really like explicitly
political cards um so council's dilemma
and will of the council I think are both
cool mechanics with a lot of cool design
space I think it's unfortunate that the
two cards from those that actually ended
up being good in EDH are some of the
less interesting ones but I think
there's there's plenty of other design
space I think it'd be cool if they
printed more of those type of cards um
and I think go is actually go is a super
cool mechanic I love go and I think it
would be neat to kind of expand the
mindset of go outside of creatures just
because I think goat has kind of a
natural power limitation that uh it's
not going to be good above kind of the
the Bey mid-range level of power um and
I think that's valid for a type of card
to be but it would be neat to see more
cards that are kind of explicitly
political but play around with other
resources like cards in hand and that
sort of thing uh I think the I don't
remember what the mechanic is called
demonstrate maybe uh the one where you
can copy a spell if you let an opponent
copy it as well I think that one's kind
of neat that's that's cool um so yeah I
think I think more stuff like that would
be
neat what's the most memorable deck
you've played
against sometime last year I played
against
a timna jesa tribal ball lightning deck
and that deck's vision is Splendid to me
I I love Decks that that take a
really you know juicy powerful Commander
or pair of partner commanders and use
them for ridiculous end I just love that
and I love the idea of Swinging with a
ball lightning for 18 at somebody's face
that's just that's a vision I can
appreciate let me tell you so I I I'd
have to go with that deck that's that's
the only one that comes to
mind
cat I've gotten a handful of comments
asking about the cat post and the
implied cat that goes with it uh and
thankfully he made an appearance for
this uh so this is uh this is my boy
Nico he loves to bounce off the walls
when I'm trying to record so yeah he's a
great
guy